the problem is that we've built a  society filled with people who cannot  handle any amount of frustration at all  they can't carry on let alone Thrive  they collapse and they melt into a  puddle and rather than than converting  frustration into opportunity which is  what successful people do they look to  convert everything into pity but I pity  the food because that's the only  currency they're interested in  collecting and the fundamental issue is  that while while nobody wants to work  these people actually think that they  shouldn't have to they don't just wish  for the magical genie they think that  the world owes it to them and when the  world doesn't give them what they  believe they're owed they only cave into  themselves even farther feeling not only  sorry for themselves but also aggrieved  as though the very realities of human  existence are an attack on them  personally you cannot function as an  adult this way